what was the experience like for you
seeing the show
like watching it back i lived it so i
was like
prepared for the shower scene and i was
prepared for the dates and stuff like
that so i had
like a year to like just mentally like
get ready for what was it
right the hit reality dating show saw
singles from around the world put to the
ultimate test
as they attempt to form emotional
connections without physical contact
there are conditions to your stay here
no kissing or sex
of any kind
oh do you have any regrets like watching
it back or no looking back at it i mean
i kissed with haley was my one of my
favorite moments it was oh my god
it was like such like a fun few days for
us when before it was revealed that it
was us like we were running around like
little minions like it was a lot of fun
but
the thing i would probably say i would
regret would be like the shower scene
with cows that didn't necessarily need
to happen i'm not the person to like
have to chase a guy or like anything
like that but
obviously like i
really don't think that i've been able
to like get you out of my head
so you filmed this a year ago so you and
harry are basically about to like see
each other and seek right
all that time yeah and then of course
now yeah and now you're quarantined
separately so how you guys maintaining
this one because when was the last time
you saw him
the last time i saw him was right before
quarantine happened so
it was the very end of february
beginning of march and then
home to visit my family in ontario and
while i was in ontario
all of this stuff happened we just
remind each other like this is gonna be
over soon
this isn't gonna last forever like our
relationship has been such a test from
the beginning so as long as we can get
through these next few weeks or next
like
hopefully not few months then i think
it'll be solid were you guys talking
about possibly getting married in order
to get over the border
yeah because i was looking it up and
you can come to canada if your spouse is
here
like we were already talking about
getting engaged and like looking at
rings
i want to marry you you want to marry me
of course we'll celebrate it later but
like if that's what we got to do like
100.